papaux et maintenant vivre les costauds
c'est le nouveau nom qu'on va donner à
l'équipe de france de handball les bleus
qui avait été champion du monde il ya
cinq ans on les appelait les barjots
maintenant on va les appeler les
costauds en particulier après la superbe
victoire hier soir contre l'allemagne en
quart de finale dans les toutes
dernières minutes grâce à un but de
monsieur jackson richardson le capitaine
qui a marqué à 7 secondes de la fin du
temps réglementaire formidable julien
est riche en quarts de finale des
championnats du monde de handball
les allemands mènent 22 21 il reste
quinze secondes de jeu les bleus ont la
balle et jackson richardson prend les
choses en main un tir incroyable à
l'instinct dit il un but qui offre aux
français les prolongations puis la
qualification
à vrai dire hier il n'était pas dans son
meilleur jour
mais jackson richardson et de ceux qui
en un geste de génie vous change une
rencontre richardson est un grand talent
fou quoi laisser faire des choses avec
un ballon normal que que pratiquement
personne d'autre au monde de se faire et
ça limite c'est que parfois il a n'est
même pas consciente 31 ans natif de la
réunion
richardson a promené sa coiffure rasta
et son talent sur tous les parquets du
monde médaillé de bronze à barcelone
champion du monde à helsinki
on parle souvent de lui comme on parle
de zidane ou de michael jordan
sans vouloir comparer disons que jackson
est désormais lui aussi l'emblème
incontestable de son sport en toute
modestie
justement d'apporter un peu plus mon
expérience mes connaissances au niveau
international avec qui j'ai du vécu mes
jeux
mais je me reste que je reste quand même
en face au partizan moi c'est pour moi
lamballe c'est un jeu
un peu grand frère souvent meneur
d'hommes et assurer mon génial
richardson est incontournable